[Musique]
laurent sinclair clavier juges ou des
simples et avec taxi girl alors vous
êtes un groupe indé groupe français qui
a plus frappé ces dernières années on a
beaucoup causer de vous à cause d'une
histoire de mec n'est ce pas 2 une
histoire garçons 1
vous avez vendu pas mal de disques
vendus combien de disques de chercher le
garçon louis 200 300 milles single donc
trois fois disque d'or avec cherchez le
garçon
le disque dans pour les singles ces cinq
cent mille 500 lui n'a pas encore les
albums et les albums un peu plus de 50
minutes
oui donc ça veut dire que vous êtes une
des plus grosses ventes des groupes
français à partir de là vous avez créé
avec votre manager alexis un label qui
s'appelle comme ça oui mannequin les
cordes et vous produisez maintenant vous
même des gros oui on a créé le label
parce que on était chez pathé marconi
avant et
c'est un peu tous font quoi les majors
compagnies françaises et on a créé le
label avec l'argent que nous en rapporte
et cherchez le garçon
on a signé un groupe dans lequel on qui
sont des amis à nous ayons vraiment une
croyait complètement scellé civile le
civil oui on est très content de voir
que le 45 tours marche la crise la crise
je crois que beaucoup de gens
connaissent et tout ça passe un peu
partout dont on a signé aussi état major
et le groupe de claude peron ancien
chanteur de métal urbain wilson 17 qui a
été un des groupes les plus importants
pour nous on a signé aussi leur compte
mais moi j'aime bien et puis là on
attend on a des projets à leur a dit
roman sa bombe de l'île puis louis saez
un groupe de paris alors quel est pour
toi la différence pour un groupe de
signer avec des gens comme vous et avec
une maison de disques mise à part que
c'est des copains qu'ils avaient des
relations la main d'oeuvre la différence
les noms
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien la place
du groupe chez nous c'est non mais ça
sérieusement c'est génial ça c'est
génial pour nous travailler avec au
niveau du contact déjà
ouais enfin on est on est tous on est
toutes les musiciens c'est uniquement ça
veut dire en fait on fait ça parce que
c'est en rien faire d'autre et c'est ça
qui nous intéresse
eux ils sont comme nous et nous on est
comme eux
on travaille ensemble pour la même chose
mais comment vous distribuer ces dix
mannequins rico on travaille avec son
origine
et ça se passe très très bien on
s'entend très bien l'exemple gym et je
pense que ça aurait été très difficile
avec n'importe quel est mon côté maison
glisse mais l'origine c'est ça a été
d'abord un petit label aussi et c'est
devenu aujourd'hui ont super bien marché
sont venus une vraie maison de disques
en grande maison dit et ils ont ils ont
guéri de conserver la souplesse de
des petits labels et l' envie d'inventer
d'essayer des trucs que vous avez les
moyens de faire de la pub sur ces
nouveaux groupes
on en parle de vous assurer des choses
pour leur tournée leur concert au bio se
démerder tous les moyens non mais on a
les moyens on les donne les moyens ça tu
les trouveras quand il ya un truc sur
lequel que tu crois vraiment être les
moyens des trous
[Musique]